[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce 7 8 sociétés
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du manger
local les consommateurs se tournent de
plus en plus vers le circuit court vers
les producteurs locaux avec pour
motivation de mieux manger protéger
l'environnement ou encore préserver sa
santé invité sur ce plateau bertrand
houillon vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonjour à vous
chargé du développement durable et de la
ruralité hervé givry également bonjour
vous êtes maraîchers pardon à magny les
hameaux je vais y arriver à retrouver
les places des uns et des autres et
julien castagnet qui est en charge de la
création de l'amap notamment des racines
et des graines sur sur elancourt elle
fasse avoue didier houssin demi bonjour
vous êtes président de l'amap 100%
villepreux et laurence morel au second
vous êtes adjointe au maire de
villepreux et on va parler notamment
avec vous tout à l'heure du travail que
vous avez mis en place pour créer l
cette amap sur villepreux on va parler
donc des initiatives du travail de
chacun et puis aussi et bien sûr de la
pérennité possible ou non de ce système
mais comme lors de chaque émission voici
un nouveau documentaire à découvrir
miren une bergère basque elle élève
seule deux enfants un troupeau de 170
brebis elle illustre malgré ses doutes
la réussite d'une agriculture encore
inscrite dans le respect est des cycles
et du vivant un documentaire signé jane
bourgon pour san aussi production
[Musique]
jeudi
je ne doute pas de ce que je fais
aujourd'hui même dans l'année parce que
je sais ce que ce que je vais produire
ce que je vais vendre ce que je vais
avoir comme charges à payer donc ce que
je vais avoir comment revenus mais par
quoi je doute parce que vu l'évolution
des choses de manière générale c'est
très très inquiétant et je doute pour
l'avenir je doute pour l'avenir proche
même dans cinq ans je me dis mais on va
enfin commencer à mettre 5 en mai
[Musique]
à paris
il y aller
[Musique]
momo
mo
[Musique]
oh
o o
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin
alors quand je me suis installé en 2000
hommes j'y reviendrai de faire du
fromage de l'attendre l'atome c'est le
fromage traditionnel ici au pays basque
on va dire on ne fait que de la tempe en
ruby et moi j'avais depuis le début
l'idée de faire autre chose que la
tendre voilà des lactique de ses pâtes
molles
je voulais obtenir un fromage j'avais
une idée très précise en tête de ce que
je voulais comme comme textures comme
croûte comme commandeur comme au bout
comme en consistance mais je n'avais pas
comment il fallait faire pour arriver à
ce fromage je n'arrivais jamais à ce que
je voulais et puis un jour par hasard
j'ai obtenu le fromage que j'avais envie
de d'avoir et le lendemain ça pas marché
j'ai continué à essayer
et puis quatre ans après j'ai obtenu à
nouveau sur fromage que j'avais envie
d'obtenir est là quand j'avais un peu
fait un peu d'expérience à leur hameau
est bon je commençais à comprendre
pourquoi
et donc j'ai essayé une deuxième fois la
deuxième fois ça marche les gc une
troisième fois ça marche et ainsi de
suite
j'ai le fromage de mes rêves en fait
[Applaudissements]
maintenant que j'ai surmonté les
épreuves les plus difficiles dues à
l'installation à l'apprentissage du
métier c'était rare je me dis que ces
séquences puisque que j'adore faire et
je changerais de métier pour rien au
monde
[Applaudissements]
mais j'étais pas j'étais pas très très
soutenu parce que le ressenti que
j'avais à l'époque c'était que mais que
voilà je ne faisais pas confiance on me
prenait un peu pour pour quelqu'un qui
rêvait qui idéalisent est le métier sans
le connaître et
c'était sans doute le cas mais
maintenant avec quinze ans de plus
aujourd'hui je peux dire que je prenais
le métier mais je courais je prenais
toutes les difficultés je connais les
joies du métier et là je peux vraiment
pesé le pour et le contre et gégé aucun
d'autres que j'ai fait le bon choix
voilà je sais pas si je vais pouvoir
faire ça jusqu'à 60 65 ans mais voilà
tant que 1 que je peux le faire mais je
continuerai points
à ma remarque on est short yade ou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma chronique je retiens downing street m
mr
des et et les mécontentements se jetant
du bois un terrain de chasse aux
pèlerins biais là
là cette année je suis contente parce
que je suis tranquille ça se passe bien
je suis plus rigoureuse aussi parce que
je suis là parce que les filles je
laisse tout seul et je suis pas aussi
une quête que tu vois il ya un an déjà
jeu
je m'appelais un peu le travail pour
vite retourné au aux enfants et après le
lendemain je retrouvais l'agneau
complètement voilà et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en effet
je considère pas vraiment ça comme
métier
c'est plus en mode de vie c'est pas
comme si c'était un métier que j'ai
exercé la journée pour ensuite le soin
rentrer chez moi et faire ce que j'ai à
faire ce que j'ai envie de faire ma vie
privée c'est ma vie professionnelle et
ma vie privée c'est c'est mon métier de
berger
chaque mois
[Applaudissements]
c'était un groupe d'étudiants qui
étaient en formation agricole
donc il y avait surtout des gars ans il
y avait deux ou trois filles et alors
les garçons à un moment donné à leurs
débuts disait rien il m'écoutait il
disait rien et mon puits abandonné 1 1
qui pose la question mais qui ce qui
vient pour pour faire les travaux
un tracteur j pour faire les travaux un
tracteur mais quels travaux en tracteur
ben alors il me dit par exemple pour
faucher au pour étudier ces mois puis
mais comment ça c'est toi et puis mais
comment ça commence à ses toits et puis
à m'habitue conduit le trésor puis gb
oui mais je conduit la voiture aussi
[Rires]
et on pouvait jeter 10
à jamais
m
là
[Musique]
dans l'un dominé ce qu'est nolan johan
neeskens lyon invitait ce qu'est
e
[Applaudissements]
m
tout est dit
[Musique]
à la diète
et ce tous vos biens volés
et là
non à joan busquets
le royaume
m
à
[Musique]
tout ce que je produis et que je vends
sert à peine à couvrir les charges que
j'ai sans les primes on ne peut pas
vivre c'est pas très facile d'aborder ce
sujet en fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
alors là on va faire le fromage de verre
de l'atome de l'ossau iraty et il y à il
ya quatre traite donc il ya ceux que
j'ai j'ai récolté en deux jours et je
vais mettre la présure la maman
[Applaudissements]
voilà
c'est ma sieste
là encore c'est parce que je ne préfère
pas
après je vais faire un disque 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
voilà c'est une drôle de sensation de
devoir sur fromage sur fromaget faut
savoir que je ne vais pas fabriquer 1 2
heure je vais quand même fabriqué un ou
plusieurs mois ça démarre à la montagne
ça poursuit en notant qu'un et probité
cents à la ferme ça continue en hiver
car les agneaux mais ce qu'il faut les
faire téter et puis à la traite
voilà donc sur moi j'ai la crème une
longue histoire
c'est pas une histoire de 1 jour
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'été c'est la saison calmant après il
ya les fous et les regains à la ferme
mais bon voilà ça se résume à ça le
travail de l'été c'est ça c'est poignard
regard surveiller le troupeau à la
montagne mais voilà ce que c'est vrai
c'est beau c'est beaucoup plus
tranquille donc en été on en profite un
peu pour voilà pour sortir la plus de
temps pour la famille les amis
moi ce qui me concerne des gens j'en
profite aussi pour pour donner des
kantaldi avec mes soeurs
[Musique]
makoun la poule b 1 et monaco
meba
pourquoi pas
on ne va pas unanimité
[Musique]
moi ils m'ont
m
dans le palais
rherrabi symbolisa
oh
estac itno stick de ninh binh à bailly
dagana cheval guillaume goulet à rabat
chocoland à tous les savates semaine
ardian et par éthique antique de torquay
nycer ngor d'abyane et éthiques
au rwanda gogh ouverte scène et sur les
médias
oh
[Musique]
o o
oh
de retour sur le plateau de tv 78 avec
nos invités du jour ils sont politiques
responsables d'amap ou encore maraîchers
ils vont nous parler du travail qui le
mène au quotidien et on va débuter avec
vous et hervé givry vous êtes maraîcher
installé à la ferme urbaine à magny les
hameaux
c'est en 2013 que vous êtes reconverti
dans cette profession et janvier 2018
que l'aventuré vraiment commencé donc on
va voir parlez nous un peu de ce
parcours justement je suis parti en
formation en 2013 ensuite j'ai fait
trois ans de cause d'activité avec des
champs des possibles qui était avant une
association et maintenant qu'ils ne une
coopérative auquel je suis rattaché
puisque je suis salariée de la
coopérative dans mon activité
voilà et depuis le début de l'année je
suis effectivement à manille pour
produire des légumes pour la map
d'elancourt et de guyancourt légumes de
saison et bio c'est important sur des
lieux tout à fait oui oui c'est ce
qu'elles seront ceux de de ma
reconversion ou si oui pourquoi avoir
choisi cette reconversion aussi on dit
souvent que l'agriculture c'est c'est
plus qu'un métier difficile c'est mais
c'est quelque chose qui vous a c'était
pour mettre en adéquation mais mes
pensées et mes actes voilà ça faisait un
moment que ça tournait
d'autre part il me paraissait important
de passer à l'acte pour le regrettons
pas du tout bois pour enfin des tas de
choses et je regrette pas du tout non
alors pour commercialiser vous en avait
parlé à cette production vous passez par
une amap c'est une association pour le
maintien de l'agriculture paysanne
il y en a à lui en cours y en aurait une
prochainement encore à elancourt je
viens castanier ou comment ça fonctionne
une amap déjà une amap c'est de céder
adhérents ou des personnes qui
souhaitent se réunir en ce sens pour
soutenir un maraîcher ou une agriculture
locale non vous fait avoir aussi bien du
pain on pouvait avoir des yeux pour même
de la bière dans le coin des gens qui
produisent localement et qui produisent
bio de préférence
il ya une demande de plus en plus forte
de la part de consommateurs oui et
davantage de l'amap c'est que vous êtes
en lien direct c'est à dire que le
consommateur et le producteur
il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire entre les
deux vous êtes toujours en lien direct
vous développez actuellement la map la
future amap sur et long cours alors
c'est pas une amap c'est une association
vallée crazy d'accord elle est créée il
y aura possibilité au cirad et point
pour voilà pour les consommateurs qui
veulent retrouver les produits par
exemple pas exactement
nous ce qu'on fait c'est que on a un
lien sur lequel tout est notifié
notamment comme on bouge toutes les
semaines de biodistribution ils soient
au courant
nous adhérons sont en cours où ça se
passe il ya une autre amap représenté
ici en plateau c'est 100% ville pour
vous elle vous nous en parler nous en
parler pardon tous les deux mais tout
d'abord bertrand guillon vice-présidente
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
la ruralité du développement durable
expliqué nous un petit peu le rôle que
le politique à jouer dans ce
développement que ce soit des fermes des
lieux d'agriculture ou encore des amap
quelle place le politique peut-il
trouver dans tout ça les collectivités
aux enfers rôle à jouer aujourd'hui sur
le retour et la diversification de
l'agriculture dans le cadre de
l'aménagement du territoire dans le
cadre de l'accompagnement des
installations et et de la dynamisation
aussi en local sur la mise en relation
des des habitants avec les agriculteurs
surtout dans une dans un contexte aussi
contraint en termes de foncier que les
l'île de france très concrètement
aujourd'hui pour l'installation en
agriculture un agriculteur nez avec des
cumuls crise s'installe sur des
nouvelles terres donc et à acheter ou
louer des terres
quand on sait la pression foncière qui
existe dans nos secteurs
c'est quasi impossible si la
collectivité n'intervient pas en mettant
pourquoi pas à disposition des terres en
louant des terres elle même en remettant
des terres à l'agriculture c'est à dire
en les urbanisant pas aussi derrière on
ne favorisera pas la diversification de
l'agriculture
il faut savoir que sur un territoire
comme saint quentin en yvelines on est à
90 % de terres en céréales aujourd'hui
pour faire 2-1 pour faire revenir ou
raccourcir les circuits sur la
consommation pour les habitants en
direct on ne mange pas que des céréales
banque un moment donné il faut aussi
diversifier cette agriculture et c'est
pas aujourd'hui pour le moment sur les
terres céréalières qu'on arrive à
prendre donc il faut qu'on prenne sur
d'autres terres le travail des
politiques et a été nécessaire l'aide
des politiques pour vous pour votre
conversion pour développer votre
votre espace agricole ou encore pour la
map eux
oui et non au début au début non on se
débrouille tout seul et au final oui
puisque pour l'installation je suis je
vais aller m'installer à magny les
hameaux qui est votre commune également
je leur précise vous en êtes le maire a
où il ya un projet justement
d'installation de plusieurs agriculteurs
voient là et il ya actuellement la
construction d'un bâtiment pour pouvoir
stocker les légumes le matériel en fin
de compte puisque travailler dans des
conditions correctes mais bien sûr saint
quentin en yvelines récemment il ya eu
un séminaire sur le manger local
justement je vous propose de revoir ce
reportage que nous y avions consacré le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
est composé à 21% des espaces agricoles
à l'occasion du séminaire du manger
local une convention annuelle
d'objectifs a été signé on est sur un
objectif de pérenniser l'agriculture qui
existe déjà sur le territoire de l'aider
à une transformation vers plus de local
de conversion aussi vers beaucoup plus
de respect
en terme environnemental et aussi donc
quand c'est possible de pouvoir
favoriser les installations pour une
diversification 32 exploitation agricole
interviennent sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
mais certains agriculteurs sont entier
espère beaucoup de ce séminaire en
présence des acteurs locaux
on vit dans une région où on voit leur
bannissement prendre du terrain agricole
et mais a contrario nous on a du mal à
faire nos bâtiments
je veux de la sérénité et de la
confiance parce qu'on n'est pas là pour
juste d'être là deux ans et demi trois
ans et puis après faire autre chose vous
laisser en abandon cetc des projets de
vie qu'on met en place il ça à leur
faire comprendre aux acteurs locaux
c'est je m'aperçois vraiment que c'est
nous c'est très compliqué clément
produit une cinquantaine de paniers pour
la map local 100% villepreux qui a pour
vocation de soutenir l'installation des
agriculteurs dans leurs activités
on a plus de 115 119 famille qui est qui
et qui viennent qui se fournissent par
ce biais là tantôt comment à dire sous
forme de contrats hebdomadaire tantôt
sous forme de contrats bimensuel les
amap association pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne permettent une
vente directe sans intermédiaire entre
le producteur et le consommateur 100% du
montant du panier est reversée aux
paysans le 7 8 sociétés se poursuit avec
aujourd'hui cette thématique autour du
manger local on a entendu parler et on
vous a vu dans ce reportage également
sur la mappe de villepreux
quelle a été la motivation déjà pour
lancer la map comment ça s'est passé il
y avait une volonté politique et vous
avez aidé ou celle inverse
il sait
déjà c'est pas un hasard que ce soit ça
se soit fait à villepreux nous amusons
nous avons un territoire qui est très
majoritairement agricole 65% de la
commune est en terre cultivée donc ceci
explique cela
déjà aussi ont bénéficié d'une situation
où il y avait énormément de bio sur
l'ensemble de l'agglomération on est à
peu près à 8 % de terres en bio à
villepreux on est à plus de 22 % et ce
depuis plusieurs années déjà
donc on bénéficiait de sein est en fait
par un hasard des circonstances j'ai
rencontré deux jeunes agriculteurs qui
venait de s'installer sur la commune
et là tout de suite je me suis dit qu'on
tenait quelque chose un filon parce que
c'est une ville qui s'agrandit on est
passé à 11500 et bientôt treize mille
habitants je savais très bien que les
familles et voilà il ya vraiment un goût
pour pour ses circuits courts pour
comment dire manger local manger bon et
donc quand ils m'ont expliqué tous deux
que il souhaitait vendre uniquement via
des amap jardim a coûté banco pour lunel
était déjà en activité elle l avait elle
produisait des oeufs bio donc je vais
simplement demander si elle avait encore
un volant de production disponibles ce
qui était le cas
donc en fait la première rencontre a eu
lieu en février 2016 et les premières
distributions de à l'époque on faisait
ça dans des commerces de la ville qui
nous prêtaient leur leurs locaux
façon gratuite ça permettait aussi de
faire connaître des commerces de la
ville
et ça a commencé je crois au mois de mai
ou juin 2016 donc ça s'est fait très
vite et pour le 2ème agriculteurs ça a
été plus long parce que lui il était en
phase d'acquisition de terres donc sur
la commune et là vraiment comment à dire
les adhésions des amapiens et le soutien
financier parce que dans le système de
la map ce qu'il faut bien expliquer aux
gens c'est que en amont de la récolte
des paniers les adhérents règle
directement à l'agriculteur l'ensemble
de leurs contrats annuels ou voilà donc
voilà il paye d' avance donc c'est bien
pour ça qu'on dit que c'était pour le
maintien de l'agriculture paysanne parce
que pour eux c'est vraiment une
pérennisation de leurs voix lasse et
leurs rentrées financières sont 100
sécurisé donc grâce à ça même s'il
n'avait pas encore produit
ça lui a permis de passer au travers des
fourches caudines je dirais d un des
bancs de la safer et on a vraiment
accompagné moi en tant qu'élus et puis
après l'association qui s'est créée
parce que c'est vrai qu'après sur le
territoire c'est grâce à des bénévoles
que que l'association fonctionne au jour
le jour mais disons que ce qui est
sympathique dans une amap c'est que
vraiment c'est la conjonction c'est le
point de rencontre de différents
dynamique à la dynamique des
consommateurs des des clients on va dire
consom'acteurs on dit maintenant il y a
la dynamique d
des bénévoles de l'association il ya les
agriculteurs et il y a les politiques et
en fait comment un gars quand tout ça se
conjugue nous on a eu un petit
alignement des planètes mais dans ce cas
le résultat justement pour pour la map
jusqu'à présent sur villepreux basket ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est mieux
n'importe quoi dans cet amas possible
vous êtes précisé mais pour l'instant ça
c'est en train de se développer donc là
là bas c'est quand même le travail du
maraîcher qui nous font 10 des légumes
on a aussi donc florence molière qui
nous fournit du miel des fruits rouges
et des oeufs
ah que tout récemment donc on a fait des
contrats avec un meunier boulanger donc
ça c'est assez extraordinaire c'est
quand même assez rare parce qu'il se
trouve qu'il ya des départs 7 céréalière
qui sont déjà cultivées en bio depuis
des années et ce jeune meunier boulanger
donc qui est aussi une personne quittant
reconversion achète le grain fabrique
lui-même sa farine et ensuite fait son
pain donc la presse des villes de blé
des moyens de vite on est vraiment hyper
local quoi voilà et après ça n'empêche
pas que il y aura d'autres d'autres
possibilités sur le territoire y est
aussi un producteur de pommes et de et
de poids donc voilà tout ça c'est tout
un tas de choses à développer mais qui
sont extrêmement chronophage pour les
bénévoles
il ya un échange entre les amap qui sont
proches les unes des autres par exemple
oublié ce qu'est une concurrence de
cette annonce est passé pas en
concurrence et généralement on travaille
soit en interne amap sur certains sur
certains sur certains gros dossiers par
exemple il ya des collectifs qui se sont
montés qui s'appelle ce qui pousse ces
différents acteurs qu'ils soient
adhérents de différentes associations
même des des personnes même sur des gros
dossiers on peut travailler en
adéquation et une volonté aussi de
s'élargir à peut-être à d'autres
agglomérations aussi de développer ce
système là d'élargir un peu vers
versailles par exemple ou pas trop on
reste sur des circuits courts mais du
côté des artistes et des actions
citoyennes qui qui se met en place
il existe déjà d'autres âmes à peu
autour de notre territoire
j'en connais une par exemple sur le
plateau de saclay proches c'est bon de
là où j'habite ce domaine il est à meaux
mais il y en ad'autres un petit peu
partout c'est en train d'essai mais ton
mieux maintenant la plus grosse
difficulté pour pour ce système
finalement de lien entre producteurs et
et habitants c'est de trouver la
production mais de trouver maintenant la
diversité de la production
on a un certain nombre de maraîchers qui
se soit installé d'autres d'autres
producteurs qui qui s'installe par
exemple aujourd'hui pour trouver de la
viande bovine dans notre secteur c'est
plus compliqué pour et puis ensuite pour
trouver ne serait-ce que dec ça devient
compliqué aussi puisque on n'a pas les
productions nécessaire les productions
nécessaire pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
répondre aux besoins de nos
consommateurs qui sont qui sont ici donc
c'est toute cette cette diversification
alors il y avait un mot pendant le
séminaire qui avait été donnée par par
un professeur de l'agro paris tech et
qui est la densification de
l'agriculture cette densification c'est
tout simplement sur un même territoire
d'avoir plus de productions plus de
diversité de production pour pouvoir
mieux répondre justement aux besoins des
habitants et là c'est un vrai enjeu
aujourd'hui on parle donc dû manger
local j'ai tout de même précisé qu'il ya
ce guide qui a été édité par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui permet de retrouver
justement les adresses des amap
rencontré à les maraîchers aussi les
producteurs locaux vous saurez à qui ils
sont ce qu'ils font et où trouver leur
production je redonne ces quelques
chiffres 1 à saint quentin en yvelines
la 21 % des terres sont agricoles 32
exploitation l'a15 amap ça représente 28
emplois locaux tout de même on peut
aussi le souligner on va parler aussi de
la pérennité de tout ça juste après ce
reportage consacré à un autre maraîchers
c'est robert pirès lui aussi et
maraîchères magny les hameaux et lui
aussi s'est reconverti en 2014 et nous
étions présents lorsqu'il avait livré
ses premiers paniers de légumes
reportage
le terrain a déjà bien changé en ce
début du mois de juillet robert pirès
cultive salades choux raves courgettes
ou encore tomates en février dernier ce
maraîcher avait vu son installation
prendre forme avec l'aide de plusieurs
bénévoles
cinq mois plus tard il propose déjà des
produits
je crois tout le monde est content pour
moi en tout cas je le suis et les
retours que j'ai des gens aussi dans
l'ensemble ism.l'ism le goût des culs
des légumes
donc ça ça tient pas à moi c'est ça veut
dire que la terre répond bien
ils ne sont pas gros mais légumes parce
que j'ai une problématique d'arrosage
très limité mais du coup le goût lui il
est pas mal et on est assez content et
la quantité
je crois que c'est bien aussi
actuellement robert pirès fourni deux
amap l'une à magny les hameaux la
seconde dans le xviiie arrondissement de
paris
il livre une quarantaine de paniers
chaque semaine bon faut être un peu
lapin mais moi j'aime bien j'ai démarré
de manière
précaires on va le dire pour pouvoir
démarrer vite j'arrose soit l'arrosoir
sur des petites surfaces cultivées soit
huit années minutes mans et donc je ne
peux pas beaucoup arrosé je ne peux pas
beaucoup brillé mais plan mais
mais du coup c'est quelque chose qui
pour l'instant je n'ai remarqué est
gérable même même depuis plus d'un mois
où il n'y a quasiment pas eu d'eau
simplement ça ne me permettra pas de
grandir la surface exploitée pour
augmenter mais le nombre de paniers en
faire quelque chose de rentable en
quelque sorte qui permet de tirer un
revenu
actuellement vous vivez de votre
exploitation pas non non parce que je
cherche d'abord en fait à pérenniser
mon activité c'est à dire donc j'achète
ce dont j'ai besoin
donc aujourd'hui mes revenus sont
entièrement réinvestis dans ce qui est
dans ce qui est à achat dans ce qui est
un investissement sûr d'une sur du
matériel plutôt du petit matériel
mais quand même donc aujourd'hui je
cherche pas forcément à en vivre en tout
cas prendre pour cette année la plus
j'ai démarré en milieu d'année ce qui
n'est pas là les complète même si c'est
vous dire de partir en nautisme pour
améliorer la gestion de l'eau un
chantier pour acheminer celle de la
ville va être lancé d'ici la fin du mois
de juillet robert pirès cultive pour le
moment près de 8000 m² de terrain sur
l'année il faut proposer une quarantaine
de livres ou de 80 variétés différentes
le 13 mai dernier élit dray pour la
première fois la marque nike watts
[Musique]
cet émouvant il ya quelque chose de
d'émouvant dans cette dans cette
première distribution
parce que les légumes sont là parce
qu'ils sont arrivés il avait même
plusieurs semaines d'avancé avec le avec
la chaleur et je suis très content de
pouvoir pouvoir fournir un beau panier
pour cette première distribution aux
amapiens de manille et château pour une
cagnotte solidaire avait été lancée en
février par l'association le bonheur est
dans le pré 4600 euros ont déjà pu être
récoltés ce prêt a notamment permis à
robert pirès d'investir dans un tracteur
dans cette aventure le maraîcher n'était
donc pas tout seul un élan de solidarité
qui l'encouragent à poursuivre son
activité contredire aujourd'hui que vous
êtes complètement épanoui dans cette
reconversion je me pose pas la question
tous les jours au heureusement mais moi
je
je crois que tout vient donc de voir la
l'installation d'un maraîcher sur
magny-les-hameaux la discussion qui se
poursuit en plateau est justement à
hervé givry je me tourne vers vous vous
connaissez sans doute un robert pires
qui travaillent pas très loin de chez
vous voilà semble donc c'est très très
près je vois qu'on parle de la pérennité
tout ces exploitations aujourd'hui vous
êtes reconverti vous êtes installés au
niveau marque est inquiet pour l'avenir
où vous vous dites que ce système va
durer le système va durer mais il faut
toujours trouver des nouveaux adhérents
parce qu'il ya les lui il ya du tourne
au vert tous les ans il se comprend il y
en a qui sont pas satisfaits y en a qui
les ménages voilà donc il ya du
renouvellement à faire tous les ans
étant que on n'a pas la totalité des
contrats signés
on se pose des questions bien sûr pour
les agriculteurs pour les maraîchers
aujourd'hui il est possible de vivre de
ce système durablement ou un système de
circuits courts système damas de bien
sûr ben moi j'étais j'étais en formation
chez un maraîcher qui marchait très bien
pour lui
et puis on a il y en a d'autres en
ile-de-france le pour qui ça fonctionne
mais si le temps de lancer la machine on
va dire moi je commence je suis un
débutant et donc du coup pas encore tout
à fait installer qu'on vous dit vous
êtes un débutant ça a été difficile
d'aller dans les champs le premier jour
non pas du tout non non c'est un plaisir
il n'y a pas de souci mais voilà c'est
c'est une changement un changement de
vie effectivement faut faut s'adapter
mais c'est avec plaisir n'est plus en
plus tout de même néanmoins de demande
combien d'adhérents dans les différentes
amap justement déjà sur sur votre
secteur qui appréciaient la ville pour
le monde doit être 35 je pense juste en
juste pour les pour les contrats
maraîchers après comme c'est une
association la différentes choses
ça fait très très vite ses montées en
sortent très vite là on est à 103 après
on va sûrement arriver à 150 dc dc mais
avec des adhérents qui qui reste il n'y
a pas trop de turnover il ya de plus en
plus des blacks pour le son c'est par là
qu'on voit la main des noms de nos
premiers six mois mais d'après le
sondage que j'ai faits auprès des
adhérents qui aura peu de turnover et on
a beaucoup de légendes et des systèmes
ce système comment dire
comme c'est comment dire vous ne pouvez
pas intégrer les personnes volontaires
au flux 2d semaine tout au long de
l'année en fait on clôt les inscriptions
après l'agriculteur calculs ces semences
en fonction du nombre de panique il à
fournir et puis après ils ré ouvre les
inscriptions quand tu es donc pas
pendant cette ce laps de temps et des
gens qui continuent eux à s'inscrire et
donc nous par exemple on a des listes
d'attentes
très très important et après c'est vrai
que c'est rassurant pour le maraîcher à
voir des gens en lice nature celui ci
s'est jamais des gens partent au moins
il y en aura d'autres qui aura laissé
moi j'ai déjà assez temps de commandes
expérience dans une autre amap ailleurs
et je dis qu'il faut être vigilant face
et à la map d'être vigilante parce que
c'est quand même une économie qui est
assez fragile et et l'important en fait
que s'il faudrait absolument que ce soit
de donnant donnant on va dire vous vous
achetez votre panier mais d'un autre
côté il faut que le maraîcher puissent
vivre décemment de sa de son train est
coincé
les sorties de la charte des amap des et
justement les particuliers au niveau des
tarifs ou mais ça coûte adéquat c'est
très intéressant parce que dans la
mesure où vous sauter un intermédiaire
commercial l'association
elle n'a aucun comment dire elle ne se
prend aucune marge sur les paniers en
fait donc en fait les gens adhèrent à
l'association la plupart du temps c'est
une dizaine d'euros à l'année et ensuite
le règlement que les amapiens foncé en
direct
vers le producteur donc nous si j'en
juge de notre expérience à nous quand
les personnes viennent récolter leur
panier c'est l'équivalent à chaque fois
de deux grosses cagettes de légumes donc
il ya en moyenne le 15 15 à 18 kg de
légumes en bio et chaque panier
le tarif qui a été fixé par
l'agriculteur est de 23 euros alors
montrez moi une enseigne aux ferries
donc c'est pas seulement un truc
écologique voilà pour les faits bien que
ce à partir du moment où elles font
l'effort c'est vrai et d'une de payer en
amont ça c'est un premier effort et le
deuxième effort c'est aussi le côté
participatif mais personnellement je
trouve aussi que c'est l'aspect
sympathique de la chose c'est qu'il faut
aussi donner de son temps c'est à dire
que ça fait partie de l'engagement de la
personne qui souscrit il fa va falloir
qu'elle participe à des distributions
qu'elle aide à constituer des paniers
tout ça consom'acteurs donc et pas
uniquement consommateurs nous laissent
aussi comment dire je conseille à toutes
les personnes qui ont un petit coup de
mou dans cette période hivernale d'aller
à une distribution de damas parce que
c'est formidable vous discutez avec
votre producteur ça a du sens quand je
veux dire de tout de suite de savoir à
bastien il ya moins de
carottes là maintenant pourquoi et c'est
directement le producteur qui vous
explique pour quelles raisons et si et
ça on a beaucoup de familles qui
viennent avec leurs enfants c'est ça a
du sens c'est aussi pour ça que vous
avez fait cette cette démarche en tant
que mari chez c'est aussi pour avoir du
contact avec elle et les consommateurs
échanger avec eux bien sûr c'est
important
moi je suis toujours à la distribution
toutes les semaines pour répondre aux
questions sont là et puis elle a
expliqué un peu ce qui se passe les
aléas
quand tu en as et puis pour les enfants
aussi parce que moi aussi j'ai des
enfants donc c'était c'est un ensemble
de choses là et pas mal parce que je
pourrais rajouter aussi savaient plus en
phase les gens avec le le l'évolution
des saisons parce qu'on voit on voit ce
qu'on veut quand vous êtes en vie si
vous êtes un peu hors sol vous vous
rendez pas compte du changement de temps
mais là vous voyez que là on est dans la
période de 8 des panais après il y aura
des carottes après il y aura des courges
des gens et les légumes correspond à
quelle saison pour les enfants si on
découvre des légumes ou si oui on dit
d'accord d'écouter les yeux mais puis en
même temps un moment donné va falloir
qu'on apprenne à se dire que en plein
hiver ici dans notre région on mange pas
de tomates et que des tomates ça pousse
pas souvent cellophane
dans une cachette dans une barquette en
plastique voilà même bio voilà un moment
il faut aussi revenir vers la réalité
des choses
parfois c'est un peu dur moi meme je sui
adhérents de l'amap depuis depuis
presque dix ans maintenant
la première année quand on se retrouve
avec des des blocs de terre des choux
l'hiver bon ben voilà on change un petit
peu son mode de consommation
mais c'est aussi la responsabilité tout
le monde et c'est juste la réalité des
choses et ça en connaissant directement
les producteurs ça permet de revenir sur
ces réalités
il nous reste juste quelques minutes
avant de conclure cette émission et
j'aimerais revenir sur une thématique
une dont on parlait juste pendant que le
reportage a été diffusé vous attirer mon
attention sur le fait de l'attribution
des territoires et vous avez rebondit
juste derrière aujourd'hui la
complication ses cales territoire quelle
taille de parcelles pour qu'il ya la
grille culture on met dessus et là il ya
le politique qui a un rôle à jouer
en fait c'est vrai que
les terres actuellement sont
majoritairement des terres céréalières
ou avec des productions oléagineuses et
ce sont des terrains du coût des
parcelles qui sont relativement grande
or dans le cas d'une attribution à un
maraîcher ou un arboriculteur clairement
les les surfaces souhaité sont souvent
moindre et donc cela oblige à faire des
division parcellaire et c'est la safer
qui opèrent ces division parcellaire et
c'est vrai que à ce niveau là je pense
que les politiques ont vraiment tout
leur rôle à jouer pour favoriser cela
parce que c'est vrai que ça ça fait du
coup une une commande ya une agriculture
plus vivante plus comment dire certes
avec des lopins plus petit mais ça veut
dire que chaque lopin va être comment
dire attribué à 1
maraîcher un agriculteur donc ça fait
vraiment une agriculture de proximité on
parle d'agriculture périurbaines
beaucoup plus dense et beaucoup plus
peuplé voilà c'est c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut vraiment accompagner et sur
lequel vous intervenez aussi en tant que
politique c'est c'est tout l'objet du
plan local de développement de
l'agriculture locale et des circuits
gourou qu'on débute saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est tout l'objet aussi de mon
engagement à saint quentin en yvelines à
savoir de réussir déjà à pérenniser les
agriculteurs qui sont déjà sur le
territoire céréaliers ou autres autre
type de culture qu'il puisse y avoir un
certain nombre de conversions de terre
vers une meilleure prise en compte aussi
l'environnement mais qu'on puisse
favoriser cette diversification alors il
ya un certain nombre d'outils qui qui
existe qui doivent être utilisés mais la
base c'est le politique qui ctr qu'à
partir du moment où on a des terres qui
sont publiques derrière c'est nous donc
en tant que citoyens qui devront
maîtriser ces aménagements et qui
devront permettre au fil du temps
d'avoir ces transformations de
territoire pour avoir cette fameuse
densification d'agriculture qui puisse
répondre aux besoins directs des
habitants et relocaliser finalement la
production est essentielle merci à tous
les cinq d'être venu témoigner échanger
sur cette problématique du manger local
rappelle ce guide qui a été édité par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qu'on peut retrouver auprès de
leur service et puis sur leur site
internet
aussi c'est la fin de ce sept huit
sociétés à revoir sur tv 78 points comme
et puis sur notre application mobile à
très bientôt
il
nous
[Musique]